[موسيقى]
اعرب الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس عن اسفه
لعدم اجراء الانتخابات البلديه في غزه حيث
منعت حركه حماس اجراء تلك الانتخابات
ورفضت الاعتراف بشرعيتها بل ووصفتها بانها
تكريس للانقسام وتهديد لوحده
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيين
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما مدى وجهه تبريرات فتح وحماس
لموقف ايهما من اجراء الانتخابات البلديه
في الضفه واي اثر سيتركه اجراء هذه
الانتخابات على مستقبل المصالحه
الفلسطينيه المتعثره
[موسيقى]
اصلا السلام السلام عليكم منذ الانتخابات
العامه التي اكتسحتها حركه حماس عام 2006
لم يقرب الفلسطينيون صندوق انتخابات
يقرروا مصير من يتحكمون في مصيرهم فعلوها
اخيرا على مستوى البلديات لكن الامر لم
يتم الا في الضفه الغربيه فحركت حماس التي
قاطعت الانتخابات البلديه التي جرت السبت
لم تسمح باجرائها في قطاع غزه الذي تسيطر
عليه منذ عام
2007 ادلى الفلسطينيون في الضفه الغربيه
باصواتهم في الانتخابات البلديه واختارت
حماس المقاطعه وفرضتها على قطاع غزه لتبدو
مجمل العمليه وكانما تكرس واقع الانقسام
الفلسطيني المعاش منذ انفراد حماس بحكم
قطاع غزه قبل خمس سنوات والمعادله القاسيه
التي دخلت فيها القضيه الفلسطينيه منذ اذن
الطريقه التي جرت بها الانتخابات رغم
نجاحها في الضفه من الناحيه الاجرائيه
اثارت قلق اخرين اذ حذر مراقبون من اثر ما
جرى على انقسام فريقي الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه حركه فتح انتقدت حرمان سكان القطاع
مما وصفته بحقهم الشرعي للاشتراك في هذه
الانتخابات وحملت حركه حماس مسؤوليه ذلك
وطالبتها بالتوقف عن تعطيل عجله
الديمقراطيه والعوده لاتفاق المصالحه
والتعاون لتفعيل بنوده لصالح الشعب
الفلسطيني هناك بلديات لم تجري الانخابات
فيها لاسباب فنيه تتعلق بلجنه الانتخابات
في الضفه الغربيه لكن
ايضا نتمنى ان ياتي الوقت لنطبق ما اتفقنا
عليه مع حماس وهو انتخابات تشريعيه ورئاسه
ومجلس وطني في كل انحاء الوطن حماس التي
فازت باغلبيه اخر الانتخابات البلديه عام
2005 وصفت الانتخابات البلديه الحاليه
والتي تقاطعها بانها تحايل وتنكر لاتفاق
القاهره للمصالحه وبانها بذلك لا تخدم
الفلسطينيين و وحدته المنشوده حقيقه لا
نقر بشرعيه هذهه الانتخابات بل وندعو
الى الى وقفها من اجل حمايه وحده الشعب
الفلسطيني وحمايه الارض الفلسطينيه عام
مضى على توقيع اتفاق القاهره الذي تناول
مختلف القضايا والتحديات الفلسطينيه
السياسيه والامنيه وغيرها ومستقبل هذه
التحديات ولكن الاتفاق لم يطبق بل ويقف
الان في ظل خلافات فتح وحماس على مهب
الريح اكثر من اي وقت مضى صحيح ان كثيرين
يرون ان الانتخابات البلديه ليست بذات
اهميه سياسيه كبيره بغض النظر عم من شارك
فيها او لم يشارك ولكنها تحول الانظار
باتجاه مستقبل الفلسطينيين وهم منقسمون
هكذا على انفسهم وم الات المصالحه وغير
ذلك من التحديات التي تواجههم وبينها
الظروف الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه التي تزداد
سوءا في الضفه والقطاع
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله
احمد عساف المتحدث باسم حركه فتح في الضفه
الغربيه ومن غزه معنا المتحدث باسم حركه
حماس الدكتور سامي ابو زهري استاذ احمد في
البدايه وصفت هذه الانتخابات من قبل بعض
وكالات الانباء بانها خيم عليها الفتور
وانها في الحقيقه كانت منافسه بين قاده
فتح المنقسمين اصلا هل تعتقد اذا ما صحت
هذه التقييمات لعمليه الانتخابات التي جرت
هل تعتقد ان خيار حركه فتح وخيار السلطه
اجراء هذه الانتخابات في الضفه الغربيه
بمعزل عن قطاع غزه وبعيدا عن مشاركه حماس
كان خيارا
صائبا بالتاكيد الخيار الديمقراطي
والاحتكام للمواطن الفلسطيني و الذي هو
مصدر كل السلطات ومصدر كل الشرعيات هو
قرار صائب وقرار سليم ويجب دائما ان نحتكم
لهذا المواطن ثانيا اليوم شارك مئات
الالاف من المواطنين الفلسطينيين في هذا
العرس الديمقراطي لو رايتم هذا التفاعل
الجماهيري في كل محافظات الوطن في القرى
في المدن لرايت بانها لم تكن منافسه ما
بين حركه فتح كما ذكرتم ثالثا كل فصائل
العمل الوطني الفلسطيني شاركت الجبهه
الشعبيه الجبهه الديمقراطيه حزب الشعب فدا
كفاءات وطنيه شخصيات مهنيه مستقله كل هذا
المجموع الفلسطيني شارك في هذه الانتخابات
باستثناء للاسف حركه حماس وبالتالي كيف
لنا ان نصف كل هذه الالاف المؤلفه وكل ه
هذه الفصائل ومكونات النظام السياسي
الفلسطيني بانها منافسه داخليه لحركه فتح
ثانيا هذه الانتخابات هي استحقاق ديمقراطي
واستحقاق وطني لا يحق لاحد ان يصادر مهما
كانت مبرراته الشعب الفلسطيني كما ذكرنا
هو مصدر كل السلطات ومصدر كل الشرعيات ومن
حقه ان يختار ممثليه في هذه ال الهيئات
المحليه كما هو حال المجلس التشريعي
والرئاسه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي هذا هذه
الانتخابات نص عليها القانون هذه
الانتخابات تكريس للنظام السياسي
الفلسطيني الديمقراطي وكما قال الرئيس
محمود عباس بان الذي ياتي به صندوق
الانتخاب هو فقط الذي يحق له حكم الشعب
الفلسطيني وليس اي صندوق اخر وهنا نشير
الى صندوق الرصاص كما جرى في قطاع غزه
وبالتالي اليوم الذي جرى هو عرس ديمقراطي
نجح بامتياز شارك مئات الالاف في هذه
العمليه الديمقراطيه لم تسجل اي خروقات لم
تسجل اي مشاكل نشكر لجنه الانتخابات
المركزيه المستقله التي اشرفت على هذه
الانتخابات بمهنيه بنزاهه بحياديه وسها
بالمناسبه التي اشرفت التي اشرفت على كل
الانتخابات السابقه سواء التي فازت بها
حركه فتح او حركه حماس دكتور سامي ابو
زهري احيانا ما يكون المقاطعون لعمليات
انتخابيه هم ابرز الخاسرين من هذه
المقاطعه او قرار المقاطعه هل تعتقدون
الان بعد ان جرت الانتخابات وحظيت او
اتسمت بما اشار اليه السيد احمد عساف من
نجاح وشفافيه ونزاهه وما الى ذلك هل
تعتقدون ان خياركم بالمقاطعه كان
صائبا بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يعني حركه فتح من حقها ان تقيم
الانتخابات كما تريد لكن من وجهه نظرنا
هذه الانتخابات ليس لها اي قيمه سياسيه او
قانونيه وقد راينا اليوم حسب اسلاع
الارقام التي صدرت حتى الان نسبه المشاركه
في حدود 30% اذا عن اي عرس ديمقراطي يجري
الحديث في ظل هذه المقاطعه الوا من ابناء
شعبنا الفلسطيني لهذه الانتخابات الحديث
عن ان ما يجري هو عرس ديمقراطي ويجب
الاحتكام لصندوق الاقتراح الاقتراع لماذا
لم يتم سابقا الاحتكار بصندوق الاقتراع
الم يكن هناك انتخابات تشريعيه لماذا لم
تحترم هذه النتائج لماذا يتم اغلاق باب
المجلس التشريعي حتى الان لماذا تم الغاء
مجالس بلديه في الضفه المحتله واعتقال
رؤسائها واعضائها او تنحيتهم وتعيين مجالس
مكلفه من حر حركه فتح اذا حركه فتح لا
يمكن ان يقبل كلامها بشان الخيار
الديمقراطي اما لماذا قطعنا هذه
الانتخابات هذا شكل طبيعي انا فقط فقط
اريد ان ان اشير الى نقطه دكتور سامي يعني
ما بين نعت الانتخابات ووصفها بانها عرس
ديمقراطي وما بين وصفها بانها لا قيمه لها
من الناحيه السياسيه هناك مساحه يمكن ان
تستوعب الكثير من النعوت والاوصاف وعمليات
التقييم في كل الاحوال حماس وقفت منفرده
اتخذت منفرده موقف المقاطعه كيف يمكن ان
تكون هي على حق وجميع الفصائل الفلسطينيه
الاخرى على باطل او لا قيمه ل
خياراتها ما انا ساوضح ذلك هناك اتفاق
مصالح هذا الاتفاق نص على ضروره تشكيل
حكومه توافق وطني هذه الحكومه هي التي تشف
على الانتخابات الان لا يوجد حكومه توافق
وطني نحن ذهبنا الى هذه الانتخابات بدون
حكومه توافق وطني من الذي اشرف عليها اشرف
عليه حكومه نحن بالنسبه لنا في حماس على
الاقل لا اعترف ب بها بسبب عدم دستوريتها
لذلك المدخل هو تشكيل حكومه توافق وطني
ايضا المناخات مناخات الحريات غير متوفره
انت تتحدث عن خيار ديمقراطي وتعتقل من
تريد ان يشارك في هذه الانتخابات عن اي
انتخابات تتحدث النزاهه غير مضمونه وانا
اتعرض للاعتقال تكافؤ الفرص غير مضمون
وانا اتعلق اتعرض للارهاب شاركت في
انتخابات بلديه قبل وقت قليل كل من شبابنا
رشحوا انفسهم حتى الذين لم يحالفهم الحظ
الفوز تم استدعائهم وبعضهم تم اعتقالهم
بشكل ك على سبيل المثال قبل اسبوع فقط
الاخ عبد الله عوده منسق الكتله الاسلاميه
في كليه خدور التقنيه استدعي من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه في الضفه اجهزه حركه فتح
بعد 12 ساعه من الافراج عنه تم اعتقاله
على يد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في اي اجواء
يمكن اجراء انتخابات بهذه الطريقه واي عرس
ديمقراطي تتحدث عنه حركه فتح اما حسابات
الفصائل هذه فصائل منظمه تحرير هناك تنسيق
واسع بينها وهناك علاقات واسعه هذا ليس
سرا وهذه الفصائل لها مصالحها التي لا
يمكن اخفاءها ولا يمكن انكارها لكن نحن
منطقنا واضح هناك اتفاق مصالحه يلزم تشكيل
حكومه تشف على هذه الانتخابات هذه الحكومه
غير مشكله انت تريدني ان اذهب الى
انتخابات وانا تحت المقصله اي انتخابات
يجي الحديث دعني اطرح هذا السؤال اذا على
السيد احمد عساف سيد احمد عساف كيف يمكن
ان تتوقع من حماس ان تشارك في عمليه مثل
هذه وفق واعد لعبه جائه كما وصفها السيد
سامي ابو زهري وضعتها اساسا السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي لا تقبل بشريك مره اخرى
في انتخابات نزيهه يعني الانتخابات نزيهه
فقط لان حماس لم تشارك فيها ربما لو شاركت
فيها حماس لما كانت بهذه
النزاهه اولا الذي يعطي قيمه لهذه العمليه
الديمقراطيه النزيهه والشفافه هو الشعب
الفلسطيني هم مئات الاف المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وليس سامي ابو زهري ولا اي
متحدث اخر باسم حركه حماس ثاني النسبه انا
اؤكد بان النسبه اكثر بكثير مما ذكره ضيفك
من قطاع غزه وهذا ما ستعلن عنه لجنه
الانتخابات المركزيه ثالثا ذكر بانه
الحكومه الموجوده في رام الله وهي الحكومه
الشرعيه التي تشرف على هذه الانتخابات
وهذا كلام غير صحيح اما جهل بالقانون او
محاوله تشويه للواقع الجاري الذي يشرف على
هذه الانتخابات هي لجنه الانتخابات
المركزيه المستقله التي هي اشرفت على
الانتخابات السابقه جميع ونحن من القلائل
الانظمه السياسيه الموجوده في هذا العالم
الذي يشرف على هذه الانتخابات لا وزاره
داخليه ولا حكومه لجنه انتخابات مستقله
وبالمناسبه حركه حماس في كانون اول من
العام الماضي هي التي شاركت في صياغه وفي
ترشيح اسماء هذه اللجنه والرئيس ابو ماس ا
مرسومي فقط في عجاله سريعه دعني فقط في
عجاله سريعه انقل لك ما ذكرته وكاله
رويترز نقلا عن مركز المركز الفلسطيني
للبحوث السياسيه والمسيحيه استطلعت اراء
عدد من المواطنين الفلسطينيين قال اقل من
نصف المواطنين ان انهم سيدلون باصواتهم
بينما قال عدد اقل من نصف المواطنين ان
الانتخابات ستكون نزيهه يعني ما مدى ثقه
المواطنين في هذه
الانتخابات اولا نحن مجرب وخذنا منذ ان
اتت السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه الى ارض
الوطن عشرات الانتخابات رئاسيه وتشريع
ومحليه وانتخابات جامعات وكل هذه
الانتخابات تمت بنزاهه شامله الانتخابات
الوحيده التي تتحدث عنها حركه حماس بانها
نزيهه هي التي فازت بها ولدر انها اعطت
صفه المزوره عن هذه الانتخابات قبل ان
تجري يعني حاكمت على النوايا وهذا الكلام
غير صحيح هذا الكلام منافي لاراده الشعب
الفلسطيني منافي للقانون الفلسطيني منافي
للنظام السياسي بفصائل ومنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه ثانيا اذا كان ادعاء حركه حماس
بانه هي لم تشارك في هذه الانتخابات بسبب
الواقع المعاش في الضفه الفلسطينيه اذا
لماذا رفضت حركه حماس المشاركه في هذه
الانتخابات في قطاع غزه لماذا منعت اجراء
هذه الانتخابات بقوه السلاح اغلقت مقر
لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه قصير ارجو منك
ومن الساده المشاهدين ان تبقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
جميعا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء
في حلقاتنا التي تناقش مستقبل المصالحه
الفلسطينيه على ضوء الانتخابات المحليه
التي جارت الضفه الغربيه السيد سامي ابو
زهري المتحدث باسم حركه حماس ربما ما كان
مسكوتا عنه ولم تقله حركه فتح ان حماس
قاطعت هذه الانتخابات لتستغل هذه المقاطعه
تحت تبريرات زياده الانقسام الذي يمكن ان
تسببه هذه الانتخابات بين الضفه وقطاع غزه
لتتماهى باسباب شتى كيف تعلق على مثل هذا
الانتقاد
يعني نحن في حماس لسنا في موضع شبهه او
موضع اتهام حماس ذهبت الى ابعد مدى لتحقيق
المصالحه قبل ان يكون رئيس السلطه محمود
عباس ورئيس حكومه التوافق الوطني ورغم انه
نحن اتفقنا سابقا ان تكون حكومه مستقله
وليس فيها من اي من الحركتين من حماس وفتح
او الفص الاخرى ولكن قبلنا بذلك تحقيقا
للمصلحه الوطنيه الذي عطل هذه تشكيل
الحكومه هو موقف حركه فتح الذي عطل اجراء
اللقاء استمرار اللقاءات لتسميه اعضاء
الحكومه وتم تجميد كل اللقاءات وهذا دفعنا
لاحقا الى وقف عمليه التسجيل للناخبين
لانه نحن نتحدث عن اتفاق رزمه ونرفض ان
يكون هناك انتقائيه بحيث تريد فتح ان
تختار ما تريد والسيد محم محمود عباس كان
واضحا في خطابه الاخير حينما قال المصالحه
هي الانتخابات فحركت فتح تريد انتخابات
فقط انتخابات لكن باي مقاس بمقاسات
تجري في ظل انعدام الحريات في الضفه
الغربيه نتج الانتخابات في ظل المقصله
الامنيه ومن هنا يعني تضمن فوز كبير بحكم
الواقع الامني لذلك نحن قلنا يجب العوده
لاتفاق المصالحه اتفاق الرزمه و ان يكون
هذا هو المدخل الحقيقي لاجراء الانتخابات
هل كان هناك عائق عن هل كان هناك عائق
حاله دون اجرائك الانتخابات في قطاع
غزه اذا كنا نحن ننتقد حركه فتح اجراء
الانتخابات في ظل الانقسام ونعتبر ذلك هو
تجاوز الاتفاق المصالحه من باب اولى ان
يكون ذلك يعني غير مقبول لدينا في حركه
حماس ان تج ال انتخابات في قطاع غزه اذا
جرت الانتخابات في قطاع غزه هذا يعني
تكريس وترسيم ابدي للانقسام غزه هي غزه
والضفه هي الضفه وهذا شيء غير مقبول
المقبول ان نوحد الجهود لتشكيل حكومه
توافق الوطني في سياق اتفاق المصالحه وهذه
الحكومه هي التي تشف عن الانتخابات وليس
صحيحا ان لجنه الانتخابات فقط هي التي
تشرف وزاره الداخليه بالتحديد لها صلاحيات
واسعه تتعلق بتعيين اللجان لانه هي هناك
لجان مستثناه مجالس بلديه من الذي
استثنى ليس لجنه الانتخابات وانما وزاره
الداخل دكتور سامي دكتور سامي باي منطق
يكون التقاعس او عدم اجراء الانتخابات في
قطاع غزه في الوقت الذي تجرى فيه
الانتخابات في الضفه الغربيه هو دعوه
للمصالحه بينما اجراء الانتخابات في
الموضعين يشكل تكريسا انقسام لم افهم هذا
المنطق يا سيدي اي انتخابات هذه التي تجي
في الضفه هذه انتخابات شكليه تريد اعاده
الرونق السياسي لحركه فتح في ظل انسداد
الافق السياسي امامها ليس اكثر اما ان
تتحدث عن خيار ديمقراطي بينما تلاحق ابناء
حركه حماس تقول تعالوا ل الانتخابات لماذا
تقطعون انت تضعني في السجن ثم تقول لماذا
لا تشارك في الانتخابات اي انتخابات تتحدث
عن هذه هذا هذا منطق غير غير يعني لنستمع
ربما نستمع الاجابه من السيد احمد عساف
اين كانت خطه المصالحه الوطنيه في
حساباتكم عندما قررتم اجراء الانتخابات في
الضفه الغربيه
منفرده يعني للاسف ان يكون مفهوم
الديمقراطيه لضيفك من قطاع غزه هو انه
اجراء شكلي من اجل اعاده الرونق للنظام
السياسي الفلسطيني للاسف هذا يؤكد مره
اخرى بان حركه حماس حركه شموليه لا تؤمن
بالديمقراطيه وهي يعني هذه احد الاسباب
الرئيسيه التي دعتها الى عدم المشاركه في
الانتخابات السبب الثاني يعني لحظه لحظه
استاذ احمد فقط انت قفزت من من سؤال بسيط
عن حسابات المصالحه الوطنيه لتتهم حركه
حماس بانها شموليه بينما الاتهام وجه
لحركه فتح اول السلطه الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه بانها تعتمد سيف الملاحقه الامنيه
لعناصر حركه حماس لن يكون هناك مناخ اساسا
لاجراء انتخابات نزيهه اذا ما شاركت فيها
حركه حماس في ظل المقصله الامنيه التي
تحدث عنها الضيف من قطاع غزه ما علاقه ذلك
او كيف استنتجت من هذا من هذه المقدمه ان
حركه حماس
شموليه نظامها الديمق نظامها اللي حاكم هو
نظام شمولي هي لا تقوم باختيار قيادتها
بشكل ديمقراطي وهذا معروف تقوم بالتعيين
وفق نظام معين لا علاقه له بالديمقراطيه
وهذا عكس ما يجري في كل الاحزاب
الديمقراطيه التي ترتضي هذا الاسلوب على
نفسها لتطبق على عموم الش خلينا خلينا في
مساله
الانتخابات ماشي ماشي رح نظل في
الانتخابات اولا الذي يكرس الانقسام هو
الذي تسبب في هذا الانقسام والذي قام
بانقلاب دموي مسلح بالعام 2007 بقوه
السلاح سيطر على قطاع غزه وراح ضحيه هذا
الانقلاب اكثر من 1000 شهيد من حركه فتح
ثانيا الذي يكرس الانقسام هو الذي يرفض
المصالحه ويرفض الاحتكام للمواطن
الفلسطيني ويقوم باغلاق مقر لجنه
الانتخابات المركزيه في قطاع غزه ويفض
التوقيع والتنفيذ على ما وقع عليه لاكثر
من خمس سنوات ثالثا هل الاحتكام للمواطن
الفلسطيني الذي هو مصدر كل الشرعيات الذي
يكرس الانقسام ام مصاد ضت اراده هذا
المواطن ومنعه من اجراء الانتخابات ومنعه
من ممارسه حقه الديمقراطي والقانوني كما
يجري في قطاع غزه حركه حماس تريد ان تقاطع
الانتخابات هي حره قاطعت بال 96 ولكن باي
حق تحرم مليون ونص مواطن فلسطيني في قطاع
غزه بقوه السلاح من ممارسه هذا الحق
الديمقراطي المقفول بالقانون هذا السؤال
المهم ثانيا الذي يكرس الانقسام الاحتكام
للمواطن الفلسطيني ام الذهاب بعيدا بقطاع
غزه كدوله مستقله باتجاه مصر بعيدا عن
الضفه الفلسطينيه و عن القدس والاعلان عن
اماره اسلاميه في قطاع غزه كما تخطط حركه
حماس هذا هو الذي يكرس الانقسام يا سيد
وليس الاعت انك لم تجب عن مساله الملاحقه
الامنيه في قطاع في الضفه الغربيه وكيف
يمكن اجراء انتخابات نزيهه في ظل هذا
الواقع من الملاحقه الامنيه لعناصر حركه
منافسه لكم او لحركتهم في تلك
الانتخابات اولا حركه حماس شاركت في
انتخابات الجامعات بالكامل من جنين الى
الخليل وهزمت في جميع هذه الانتخابات
لانها يعني المواطن الفلسطيني اكتشف الفرق
الكبير ما بين شعارات حركه حماس وممارسات
حركه حماس هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى حركه
حماس تستخدم هذه المبررات والذرائع للتهرب
من الانتخابات للتهرب من المنافسه للتهرب
من المصالحه ثالثا نسبه المسجلين في لجنه
الانتخابات المركزيه من اصحاب حق الاقتراع
اعلى نسبه في العالم اكثر من 75% من ابناء
الشعب الفلسطيني في الضفه الفلسطينيه
مسجلين لدى لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه
رابعا اليوم العديد من كوادر وقيادات
وعناصر حركه حماس شاركت بهذه الانتخابات
والصور التلفزيونيه التي اظهرت ذلك في
الخليل في طول كرم وفي وفي رام الله حيث
قاموا بدعم قوائم منافسه لحركه فتح من اجل
محاوله الحاق الهزيمه بمرشحين حركه فتح لم
يتعرض لهم احد ولم يقم احد بمسائل التهم
اليوم يراقب على الانتخابات اكثر من 6000
مراقب اربع 4600 مراقب محلي تابعين لقوائم
واحزاب سيد احمد يعني انت لم تلمس باجابتك
عصب السؤال الذي طرح طرحناه وطرحه الدكتور
سامي ابو زهري المتعلق بالمناخ الامني
الموجود في الضفه الغربيه الاعتقالات انت
لم تتع
الا هذه الدعاء يا اخي محمود هذه ادعاءات
من قال لك بانه كلام السيد زامي ابو زهري
هو الحقيقي هذه ادعاءات ومحاوله استنساخ
لما تقوم به حركه حماس في قطاع غزه على
الضفه هكذا حركه حماس تعامل ابناء حركه
فتح في القطاع وبتالي محاوله استنساخ دعني
اتحول الى الدكتور سامي ابو زهري دكتور
سامي هل لديكم تصور معين لمساله المصالحه
الوطنيه عقب هذه الانتخابات التي اجريت في
الضفه دون
غزه انا هذه الانتخابات ليست نهايه المطاف
نحن متمسكون بالمصالحه وسنبذل كل جهد ممكن
للعوده
لبرامج تنفيذ اتفاق المصالحه الذي عطل
المصالحه حقيقه هو الذي قال صراحه
المصالحه هي الخ انتخابات هو ينتقي ما
يريد وينفي ما يريد الذي عطل المصالحه هو
الذي قال انني اريد ان تعود اللجنه لتسجل
في سجل الناخبين في غزه لانتخابات السلطه
اين انتخابات المجلس الوطني اليست هذه
انتخاب انتقائيه لماذا لم يبدا تسمي دعنا
لان الوقت ربما لا يسمح
بالاستفاضة متمسكون بالمصالحه
وفتحوني جب ان يعني بدل كل الجهود لاتمام
المصال قضيه الانتخابات البلديه لن نتوقف
عندها في حركه حماس وكل ما فعلنا اننا
رفعنا الشرعيه عنها وهذا ما ادى الى هذه
المشاركه الضعيفه 30% في هذه الانتخابات
طيب استاذ احمد عساف في دقيقه لو سمحت ما
هو تصوركم لمستقبل المصالحه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه بعد هذه الانتخابات ا اول اولا
المصالحه الوطنيه يجب ان تتحقق من خلال
تنفيذ ما تم التوقيع عليه ونعم المصالحه
هي الانتخابات لان الشعب الفلسطيني هو
مصدر كل الشرعيات ويجب ان نحتكم له لا ان
نصادر حقه لان هذا الحق فردي ثالثا فاقد
الشيء لا يعطيه ليست حركه حماس التي بحاجه
الى تثبيت شرعيتها الوطنيه بعد ما كل ما
قامت به هي من توزع الشرعيات في
الانتخابات او غيرها وبالتالي نحن متمسكون
بتحقيق المصالحه متمسكون بانجاز ما تم
التوقيع عليه وهذا يكون من خلال الاحتكام
للشعب الفلسطيني بانتخابات رئاسيه وتشريع
ومجلس وطني ولكن المهم ان توافق حركه حما
ان تسمح للجنه الانتخابات المركزيه من
العمل بقطا في قطاع غزه بحريه كما هو
الحال في الضفه الفلسطينيه شكرا شكرا
جزيلا للسيد احمد عساف المتحدث باسم حركه
فتح في الضفه الغربيه المحتله ونشكر كذلك
ضيفنا من قطاع غزه المتحدث باسم حركه حماس
الدكتور سامي ابو زهري بهذا مشاهدينا
الاعزاء تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله غدا في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد دمتم بكل خير
والسلام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عليكم